yeah I mean I love the UK it's just like
when you go back there for a long time a
lot of little things just build up and
build up and you get reminded oh okay
this is why I moved out in the first
place yeah I saw you into a Cornwall as
well yeah that was nice yeah almost
beautiful like yeah it felt like a
different country I always wanted to go
there and yeah to drive there yeah
we're gonna get to Japan
yeah Connell is such a goddamn pain to
get Southwest
London Beyond Nutley and crapnel there's
a place right right in the corner at the
bottom left corner very very nice place
though yeah stay like these really
beautiful picturesque fishing towns and
things had like a real pasty for the
first time it was good nice
um yeah I went to Cornwall because uh my
UK mates took me there for my UK stag do
and uh that's where I had my stag
um yeah and we went there was my first
time in Cornwall [ __ ] beautiful
weather we tried surfing for the first
time and I was just like this is I can't
believe I'm doing this in the UK also
surfing [ __ ] hard
I think balancing on water was going to
be easy balancing on water okay I didn't
realize you needed that much you know
upper body strength right
for some reason I just thought okay so I
think it's all about keeping the balance
and you know you know being able to swim
being a strong swim and stuff like that
what I didn't take into account is you
know to get up when you're bored you
have to do like a push-up on water every
time yeah and like by the end of my
first surfing session my like my my arms
were jelly like my legs and everything
were fine it was like my arms I gave out
first were you able to master it to some
degree I was able to stand up my
surfboard it was one of the most it was
it was so like just satisfying to like
do that because have you ever been
surfing before no no I kind of like to
do it but yeah yeah again I don't know
special trash it's a lot of fun
yeah probably really interesting yeah
what about swimming Cornwall
um it's not really that big is it it's
your legs just like this it's like I'm
standing up guys unbelievable
unbelievable how long how many hours it
take you to get from like scratch to
being good honestly we were just there
for like one day and I wouldn't say I
was good but by the end of like the
first session I was able to stand up on
the surfboards which was
just a matter of time literally right
rode the wave along yeah yeah so you you
uh you catch the wave and you rode it to
the end it wasn't like a big wave it was
just like a little baby wave because we
couldn't go too deep in and I think
actually like it takes more effort as a
beginner I think it's like similar to
snowboarding or something where it takes
more effort to learn it as a beginner
because you're like constantly falling
down more and it takes more effort to
like pick yourself up on like the
shadower side it's also like just a
whole new like set of movements your
body's just yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly would you do it again I [ __ ]
I became like a [ __ ] surfer dude when
when trying it for the first time yeah I
was like yeah did you see we catch that
wave bro bro
it's kind of like it's kind of like you
just gotta like learn by feeling and
it's so hard to describe what you're
doing so you're like you you see the
wave coming and then like you turn
around and then you like start paddling
and as the waves come you start catching
it like you feel the momentum going and
then you just feel like oh and this rush
comes up and then you like try standing
up I'm doing such a bad job of
explaining it explaining it yeah and
it's like you know a lot of feeling yeah
snowballing I guess there are technical
terms but it's hard right to explain
yeah and it's like what pal
yeah and uh yeah I guess yeah what is
that what is that you want to drink
you want to drink some of the alcohol
all right should we shall we bring the
alcohol out no if you insist car all
right all right what we've got for us
here Chris I've tried so many of these
because of you good afternoon
apparently we found uh one in our fridge
so I said you give gifts it's the last
time yeah
Cheers Cheers
[Music]
getting fit
carb loading right throw we got carb
loadings live that's nice yeah from
Fukushima Fukushima ah nice nice
to be like surfing though um you know
who started surfing recently who Felix
oh okay
he I'm sorry I met him for the first
time with with Connor the other day it's
a very nice blow can he yeah that's
Felix trap what's he done he's a
YouTuber yeah he was a nice bloke it's
an interesting like I think if you met
him without knowing anything to do with
him like yeah normal bloke yeah and
that's the essence of why he's
successful
he's a very like nice down to earth guy
um he's saying you're not Chris please
one of the first things he said to me we
went to this Batting Center right round
one yeah yeah yeah yeah you know hitting
Bulls like he does he loves it I've got
a [ __ ] scratch the balls and why like
Felix and I'm just standing watching he
just told me a story of how in Sweden
one of his teachers told him that
someone got hit in the groin with a with
a baseball died and I was like this is a
very good conversation like the first 10
minutes that I've known you someone like
having their balls battered and dying
from it and he's like yeah don't don't
do this that's possible that's what I
determined I've debated that for like 10
minutes it is nuts just like explode
shock
heart attack yeah he didn't really go
beyond that right it was quite an
interesting sort of opener to our
friendship
um
we went to this like vegan restaurant
where they were like we have a CBD menu
would you like to see it and we're like
yeah all right they brought out this
menu and you can just like lace your
drinks with CBD oh yeah yeah she's just
literally water there's nothing yeah but
we did it we tried a fair bit and it
just just rubbish yeah it depends on
like kind of a weird CBD yeah yeah
if CBD did something it wouldn't be a
thing in Japan they were bad like that
because they they have a zero tolerance
policy on drugs or anything like that
yeah yeah unless it's alcohol cigarettes
in which case go [ __ ] crazy yeah and
they give you free yes we are
rejuvenating the Japanese economy we are
yes yes we're saving Japan right doing
what the Japan government has asked us
to do as young and it's kind of crazy
how short-sighted that announcement was
I just can't fathom it but also makes
total sense of Japan shall we let in
foreigners rejuvenate the economy take
advantage of the weekend now let's make
all the young people alcoholics
fantastic strategy what could possibly
go wrong I'm so done with the whole
[ __ ] why is Japan open I think by the
time this episode's out yeah probably
there's literally no more phases it can
be they keep inventing like another
phase so now at the time of filming
they're on the Thanos face
a tour company but they don't supervise
you yeah yeah you have to be on a on a
package tour
but for any but for individuals for an
individual but yeah and you're
unsupervised yeah what except you are
supervised they just the tour agencies
have to call you up to be like hey
seriously are you following the yeah
that you gave us and it's like and you
just have to be like yeah are you having
fun of the designated salmon restaurants
yes I'm having most fun yeah like it's
ridiculous it's so it's basically
nothing's changed like you going from an
organized group tour with other people
to an organized group Tour by yourself
yeah just hurting their own tourist
economy really I don't know I've got a
lot of comments from people who are like
I'm losing my Tempo in Japan I'm going
in Spike to South Korea instead and it's
like
[Music]
it's just very short-sighted and I just
don't know why they haven't turned
around yet and that was one thing going
about the UK game at the Europe
traveling to America everything's just
so easy moved on yeah yeah I remember
just I I flew directly to the UK to
Belgium and I landed the airport and
there was not a mask in sight yeah and I
was just like yes yeah I know Master
good and they've played their part well
but it's just like I'm so [ __ ] done
with them now yeah I think it's
frustrating for Japan we still got this
on one of the episodes just like Japan's
kind of lengths upon which they want you
to wear masks and the the yeah like they
they enforce it in such weird and
bizarre but even though there's no
mandates
it's all Theater now yeah it is like you
know you go into a restaurant and you
have to put on the mask so like you'll
go in before you get in the restaurant
off the street you'll put the mask on
you'll sit down and then you can take
the mask off and it's just like what
about this makes any logical sense you
know
is because the walk from the entrance to
your seat you could you could spread it
but not when you're sitting there
coughing eating